he does not look good he does not look
confident he looks weak he looks like
he's having a hard time giving his
argument to Charlemagne like he's trying
to defend but he can't how did you go
from well you know at least I will go
down as a president you know and that
whole mic drop on Fallon on Camel
whichever one it was and then he's like
well you know hey there's a guy in here
who believes and you know it's at the
dinner I don't know if you guys remember
that whole speech oh yeah you will never
be in the white house and then boom he
gets the White House how recent was the
Obama Charlemagne uh last week last week
last week do you have any images of that
Robin how bad was it oh just go watch it
I can guarantee you there's a reason why
this thing hasn't made it out yeah I
haven't seen any of this there's a
reason for that